el hombre fuerte de filipinas renunciará
a seguir en el poder el presidente
rodrigo duterte aseguró que no se
postulará al cargo de vicepresidente en
las próximas elecciones de mayo de 2022
y anuncio mi retiro de la política
luther te ha construido la mayor parte
de su gestión basada en la lucha contra
las drogas el 20 de septiembre de 2016
amenazó con liderar una campaña
sanguinaria contra los traficantes pero
también contra los consumidores
hay 3 millones de drogadictos en
filipinas me encantaría matarlos a todos
al menos la terna
una política brutal que provocó miles de
muertos en el país cientos de
testimonios denuncian ejecuciones fuera
del marco de la ley de narcotraficantes
en todo el territorio
cuáles son tus pecados yo que les dije
los militares por ejemplo rodea algún
peso de piso
perseguía a alguien a quien me
encarcelen
pero a paul hongo mis únicos pecados son
las ejecuciones extrajudiciales
de él en la corte penal internacional
por su parte autorizó la apertura de una
investigación el 15 de septiembre de
2021 por sospecha de crímenes de lesa
humanidad rodrigo duterte ya no es tan
popular como cuando asumió el cargo
aceptación de la que sí goza su hija
sara posible candidata a sucederlo en
los comicios de mayo donde se espera que
voten unos 60 millones de electores